when we started getting all that money
funneling into the country after the end
of World War two and the Social
Democrats were like look at us how good
socialism is working yes and it had
nothing to do with them in fact their
policies big government policies wasted
all that money and you know in the 1990s
we actually had to devaluate our
currency against the 30% of everything
was lost because of the welfare state
they built up if you listen to our
socialist Democrats or democratic
socialists or whatever the hell they are
these days I keep saying they're gonna
drop the Democrat part soon enough what
they always say is we should be more
like Sweden aoc says this Bernie says
this I doubt that AOC has ever been to
Sweden perhaps Bernie has been Sweden
but they say the Nordic countries
usually but it's specifically we should
be more like Sweden now you guys have 10
million people we have 350 million
people we have people from every walk of
life from every corner of the earth you
guys mainly were a homogenous society
into the last couple of years there's
all sorts of reasons that that analogy
doesn't quite make sense but when you
hear that America should be more like
Sweden
well what is that nothing pushes my
buttons then when I hear stuff like that
you know this comes out of the mouths of
what Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
let's clear this up once and for all
Sweden was never a socialist country in
the sense that the Eastern Bloc was you
know Soviet you know so forth
when Sweden became wealthy this was
during the the last part of the 1800s
we had a bunch of lessee fare reforms
done so we that's when we started a
transformation to industrialize we were
actually quite late to the game it was
these you know market free market
reforms that when you got the government
outlays a yes suddenly the economy
starts booming okay um August Gibbons
that is the name of the guy that was
very forward-thinking and that that made
these reforms possible and then things
started getting better yeah but better
after that the other thing you need to
remember is that when when we started
getting all that money funneling into
the country after the end of World War
two
and the Social Democrats were like look
at us how good socialism is working yes
and it had nothing to do with them in
fact their policies big government
policies wasted all that money and you
know in the 1990s we actually had to
devaluate our currency against 30% of
everything was lost because of the the
welfare state they built up so if you
hear Bernie Sanders or Warren say stuff
like we need to be more like Sweden
well the partner missing is that what
was good about Sweden was free market
oriented what was bad about Sweden we
turned out into a decent country in
spite of socialism not because of can
you add to that I can confirm that if
that is true and you can look it up it's
factual yeah so when you guys hear that
and doing what you are doing I mean it
just makes your head spin sort of gonna
smack somebody well I love my job I
really do because I get to piss people
off and I believe what Larry David once
said that if you have the opportunity to
annoy someone you should take it yeah
well you are doing now yeah you're doing
just fine it what do you think part of
the issue here is that the exterior of
Sweden looks a certain way so for
example I had two trips to Sweden to
Stockholm and I was only in Stockholm so
what of what I'm seeing is a very
snapshot version but just from walking
around Stockholm or maybe what we see in
the media if or in the movies if they
show for it someone from Sweden they're
always very tall they look very good you
know they're they're blond like you and
they're in Nice jackets and what I
noticed from walking around Stockholm
was it looked like everyone bought their
clothes that morning everyone fantastic
everything was clean the streets were
clean all those things then I get it
it's a very small little micro version
of this but is that part of the problem
that the veneer of this somehow is still
selling well or something like that
outside of your borders absolutely I
think it's sort of a Potemkin village if
you know what is that it's a backdrop
and behind it well it reminds me of
Hollywood that way yeah right yeah if
you look at it didn't
it looks good but if you look behind the
curtain you but you don't hide you're
homeless we would hide them yeah now we
can't afford to hide them anymore well
we can't hide them anymore because
you're here in California where they're
pretty much everywhere I have I have
noticed yeah so no but I think just like
not speaking out against things you
might see as wrong or incorrect it is
very important that everything looks
good if you are to have a culture of
silence and a quasi socialist state how
are you guys able to gauge how much
effect you're actually having on the
average Swede I'd say judging by the
reactions we're getting from our enemies
things are going very well yeah they get
very upset you know funnily enough like
the extreme left people they usually do
not touch me it is the social liberals
who are you know it's supposed to be
like center-right can you explain a
little bit how what the differentiation
there is for an American perspective
because I think Americans here that the
social liberals and the far-left that
sounds sort of like the same of course
yes liberal here means a lefty whereas
in Europe the word liberal is moving
that direction in Europe as well but it
still means more like the classical
Austrian liberalism
yeah I'm a European liberal yeah perfect
yeah me too that's I would use the word
you know fiscally conservative but
socially liberal to describe myself yeah
so that's where most of the attacks are
coming from on my end you know from
journalists you know people of platform
establishment media platforms they will
be very upset and they will find a
single word that I don't like in a
sentence pull it out and start a tweet
storm of you know they will tell you
things like what you're dangerous you're
a populistic alarmist
you're not taking responsibility for
what kind of people you take on your to
your show and you know going back to
this thing with a canary in the coal
mine this is the thing because Oh what
all of these people have been doing is
working so very very hard at guiding the
popular
to the correct moral standpoint at the
end of whatever they produce well you
don't do that you bring somebody else on
the show say okay this is a completely
different perspective and I'm not going
to attack you I I don't want to fight
you I want to explore your idea and just
see what I make of it they hate it they
do not want it yeah
is there anyone politically that is
echoing some of your sentiments about
what's happening in Sweden well Hanif
Bali does the job from time to time when
it his party doesn't try to rein him in
which party he's part of the moderate
party which is right-wing that would be
by American standards that would be like
like lists well what like what type of
policies would they have just because
I'm trying to get them at lower taxes
more personal responsibility and
individual choice they're trying to get
it in there but it'll basically be a
conservative really lighter like version
of the yeah I think they call themselves
liberal conservatives liberal
conservative yeah that that sort of man
that jives with me I suppose so I told
you guys that when I was in Stockholm
for the two shows with Jordan Peterson
and I saw you there that they really
stuck out well first off I was
particularly excited about them because
I knew that this small country was my
fifth most watched country and I was
like what the hell's going on here so I
sort of had Jordan also knew that a huge
percentage of his viewership was from
there so we both sort of had that date
that first Stockholm date in our minds
as something special is happening the
shows were incredible the first show
sold out literally in a minute which is
why we added the second show the
audience's were were phenomenal correct
me if I'm you're so popular there was a
black market trading and tickets to your
shows I would like to say that it was
Jordan that was very popular so just for
the record but the thing that that truly
struck me was that after the show we
would do our meet and greets and Jordan
would meet with hundreds of people mine
we would just quickly sell them
basically right before the show so I
usually get you know 30 or 40 people
because we have to do it very quick but
at the the to Stockholm shows we had
about 80 or a hundred people we jammed
all of these people into a small room
we're sitting there and it felt like
something memorable to me it felt every
they had prepared questions for you and
they had prepared for you everyone in
that room had something written down or
something on their phone or something
they wanted to hand to me or that I
should read or a story or something and
it was it was so moving to me that I
think I said to you is there a bar
around here we can go to and we took
everybody and we went to a bar and we
hung out for hours and I met some till
they told it until they closed they kept
us out and I met some of the Swedish
intellectuals that you guys hang out
with all these people anyway I'm not
even asking a question here suffice to
say that it was so obvious to me that
something is from having like an a
disproportionate amount of viewers for
such a small country of your show and
Jordans videos
well you caused quite a splash if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our international playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist there all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell